richtig eigentlich ganz lecker schmeckt
aber wie fußmatte weiteres geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut
heute haben wir das ganze mal wieder ein
bisschen anders ihr seht schon ich habe
jemanden hinter der kamera der das ganze
heute aus der hand film also ein stativ
ich finde das irgendwie ein bisschen
besser liegt das ganze ein bisschen
lebendiger vor drei vier tagen kam ein
video ich teste essens neuheiten die
halt erst im jahr 2001 auf den markt
gekommen sind das ist echt ganz gut bei
euch angekommen und ich habe ja schon
angedeutet dass ich daraus so ein
kleines format woche könnte also dass
man halt einmal versucht verschiedene
kategorien so ich sage jetzt mal
abzugrasen um halt immer die neuesten
sachen vorzustellen die irgendwelche
großen marken auf den markt bringen
letztes mal ging es um essen ich hatte
da eine cola dabei und ich habe mich
jetzt mal so ein bisschen informiert und
habe noch mal seite gefunden wo wirklich
alle möglichen getränke von a bis z die
jedes jahr neu gedruckt werden so
aufgelistet sind ich kann ich das gerne
hier mal ein werden die heißt irgendwie
sehr sehr kreativer name getränke -
news.de und ich habe damals ein roter
ist rolf und mir ist auch ihr glaubt gar
nicht wie viele getränke nahezu täglich
neu auf den markt kommen ok täglich
bisschen übertrieben aber jeden monat
mindestens 10
und die kann man doch wirklich alle
kaufen ich habe mir jetzt mal die
interessantesten hier raus gesucht das
in insgesamt neun stück und die habe ich
hier alle um die ecke im ganz normalen
supermarkt bekommen herrlichem ärzten
seien gar nicht mal gedacht ja und ich
habe davon kein einziges irgendwann
vorher schon mal wahrgenommen geschweige
denn probiert also klar hier diesem
future oder wie das ausgehen wird ich
glaube der wird sogar von coca cola
produziert haben schon mal probiert
allerdings nicht die sorte die es ganz
neu gibt es in mehr als einem monat
dann war ich sehr erstaunt über dieses
produkt dextro energy habe ich früher an
meiner schule gegessen wenn ich
irgendwie mich konzentrieren musste
ja das ist ja dieses traubenzucker zeug
das hier ist so ein battlefield energy
drink auch neu also ich glaube so das
was euch jetzt am wenigsten beeindrucken
wir dass dieser justi mit grüner tee
limette minze geschmack sekunde hören
deswegen würde ich sagen können damit
nicht wie spülmittel aber dass nicht mal
das richtig schwimmen
ok also ich will mal gespannt
also der erste geschmack ist eigentlich
ganz gut ist aber ziemlich bitter im
abgang
also überzeugt mich eigentlich nicht
[Musik]
also man kann es trinken gesteht auch
darauf wenig kalorien würde ich jetzt
aber normal meiste ist es nicht
bevorzugen so keine ahnung ich vergebe
dir mal punkte das recht von mir 5 von
10 punkten ist in ordnung
ok jetzt einmal das standard zeug weg
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt hier immer
übrigens doch so ein neues red bull das
ist dieses jahr glaube ich raus gekommen
wir machen jetzt aber weiter coca cola
energy e.on energy trading with the
great coca cola blabla
ich bin ja ein riesen coca cola fällt
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt ob ich das
produkt überzeugt
[Musik]
also ich sag mal so wenn man gerne
energydrinks mag es schmeckt halt
einfach so wie wir mal einen energy
drink ein bisschen komisch cola energien
so heißt es ja auch sogar so wie jetzt
merkt also das kann ich euch auf jeden
fall empfehlen schmeckt ganz gut kriegt
wenn wir acht von zehn punkten okay
leute wir machen weiter und zwar mit dem
nächsten produkt aquarius limette ja das
wurde am 18 märz 2009 10 gelaunt wir
haben 14 uhr
[Musik]
das wurde irgendwann im märz gelockt und
hier habe ich eine krasse vorgeschichte
dieses aquarius zurück das habe ich
früher jedes jahr im urlaub ich habe das
irgendwie nur in spanien immer getrunken
ich weiß gar nicht ob das in deutschland
schon gab auf jeden fall ist das vor
ungefähr drei monaten rausgekommen und
wir probieren das jetzt mal das ist so
eine art wasser mit limette hält damit
wäre das gedacht direkt auch in ordnung
freute mich jetzt nicht voll und ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich glaube da gibt es
bessere lösung wenn man sagt ich hätte
gerne so wasser mit so ein bisschen
geschmack cherry geschmack oder so das
kriegt von mir sechs von zehn punkten
keine ahnung also mit versicherung das
müssten eine flasche haben oder ein
getränk das zu zehn von zehn euro das
muss mich schon richtig umhauen also im
letzten video habe ich bei einer sache
bei dem essence video verlinkt ich euch
am ende und in der beschreibung habe ich
bei einer sache zehn von zehn punkten
geben und das war glaube ich habe ich
nie vergessen
und hier ist ja nicht mal zucker und
deswegen wurde hat mich das also echt
genial wenn das stimmt kann ich
eigentlich nicht viel zu sagen schmeckt
mir gut gibt volle punktzahl zehn
prozentpunkten kann ich euch im film ja
grünkohl schaut es euch an wenn das du
nicht gesehen habe okay leute ich muss
jetzt einfach mal hier mit weitermachen
und weil ich weiß wie ich denke schon
die ganze zeit seitdem ich das merkt man
gesehen habe wie schmeckt pulse
waffenschränke das eine noch viel
flüssiges traubenzucker gi fir abgesagt
kann man es sogar apfel pflaumen
hibiskus also hat das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht im traum zu gott zu tun das ist
halt einfach nur eine produktbreite also
weiße die die marke dextro energy hat
die produktbreite weiter ausgeweitet und
hat neue produkte mit ins sortiment
genommen
die sich total von den anderen produkten
abgrenzen produktdiversifikation nennt
sich das so einfach wäre
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht ich muss jetzt schon
ich muss bei dieser sache und auch bei
dieser sache sagen komischerweise die
schmecken an ungefähr ähnlich aber
keines davon schmeckt ja nur anders
weise dass man sagt da muss jetzt direkt
im laden um ihr noch welche zu holen so
halt irgendwie als wenn diese marken
versuchen verlauf kam irgendwie ein
neues getränk herauszubringen was an
sich jetzt gar nicht mal so gut schmeckt
also auch das hier hat eine 49 gekostet
ich weiß ja nicht aber überzeugen wir
organisch vier von zehn okay wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem battlefield energy
drink ich denke mal dass es irgendeine
dumme werbeaktion gibt es neues
battlefield schmeckt wie ganz normale
energy drink ich probiere jetzt einfach
mal dies indirekt dahinter
[Musik]
wer zwar noch so leichten neben
geschmack aber man schmeckt auf jeden
fall dass dieser hier deutlich
hochwertiger schmeckt der hier schmeckt
so wie diese ganzen energydrinks die man
einfach im internet bestellen kann und
damit seine eigenen marke bedrucken
können das kennen sie ja wahrscheinlich
wenn zum beispiel in unternehmen sagt er
wir machen den firmen feuer wir brauchen
endet übrigens können die im internet
10.000 energydrinks bestellen und deren
firmen logo drauf klatschen
da ist inhalt energy drink drin und das
schmeckt genauso also wenn man davon
zehn getrunken hat ist in ordnung
irgendwann aber so jetzt um das in der
freizeit mal genüsslich zu verzehren
haut sich gar nicht um also schmeckt
wirklich extrem billig 215 punkte mehr
ist nicht drin
und dieser ist aber gut also wir möchten
wieder mal acht den ich habe jetzt
bestimmt schon ein liter getränk
getrunken
macht es sinn so leute wir machen seit
das fassbrause solltet ihr eigentlich
alle kennen feiere ich mega ich trinke
auch gerne wäre so mittlerweile aber
fassbrause kann man immer trinken und
das hat also ein leichten biergeschmack
deswegen mag es vielleicht mittlerweile
noch lieber als früher
wir haben jetzt die neue
geschmacksrichtung fassbrause maracuja
ist im april raus gekommen meine ich da
bin ich jetzt wirklich mal gespannt
[Musik]
ich wollte die nämlich eigentlich schon
in den letzten partien wo ich einfach
nur essen getestet habe damit ich auch
noch ein getränk dabei ja und die war
leider ausverkauft
dann schmeckt ja anscheinend gut und ich
muss sagen finde ich echt lecker ob das
jetzt in zehn von zehn ist nicht muss
sie nur für das problem ist mega ois
kriegt von mir 9 von 10 punkten ja okay
dann haben wir zum schluss jetzt noch
red bull summer edition beach pries sich
eigentlich ganz lecker ich möchte aber
wie fußmatte grußworte das schmeckt so
als wäre da irgendwie also ohne spaß als
wenn irgendwas drin was da nicht
hingehört
das wird ganz komisch
kann ja irgendwie als wenn ihr da so
fußmatten darüber aufzubringen also ich
will jetzt auch nicht so gemeint sein
aber das gibt wirklich nur einen punkt
und sind also dann frage ich mich immer
probieren das vorher keine leute das
muss man doch irgendwie durch
verschiedene marketing abteilungen durch
müssen dass überhaupt mal raus geht und
das ist kompletter müll hat genauso
wenig traditionen wie er will leipzig
nahm es mit humor
das war's mit dem video ich hoffe es
dann gefallen lassen nach oben nach wenn
ich noch weitere getränke testen soll es
gibt wie gesagt in 2009 10 wurden schon
über 100 neue getränke gelaunt auf eure
ideen in die kommentare
check von instagram teils die alex wie
hart rein und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder 19 uhr nicht vergessen
ich muss jetzt mal aufs klo
[Musik]